عندما
حبيبي اذهب العب
الشارع مضاء بالكامل يا أختي تم استلام البضاعة
اعتبر الأسماك هي كل عائلة طواحين الهواء
[موسيقى]
يسقط
الخدعة
[موسيقى]
لعب ألعاب ألعاب ألعاب
لا تذهب بسبب
ما اسمك يا روبي مجنون بك كينزو بالفعل
وسط
المدرسة
لينين
تعال والرقص ، مشمس تعني المغازلة
الزهور في متناول اليد ، والزهور في اليابان لأول مرة
[موسيقى]
السمكة
أصعب كنت تأكل القائمة قليلا القائمة
اسم الطفل زهرة التعبئة والتغليف لطيف أرنب رئيس
الفيلة
مسحت والدتي ونقش معنى نغو أبي
يؤلمك كثيرًا عندما تضرب لدرجة أنك تقصد الحفاظ عليها
انقر فوق الخريف لذلك أجبرني على السماح لنا بذلك
شمعدان
[موسيقى]
اذهب مع
معطف الذيل للذهاب معها
لؤلؤة
انا اذهب معك
هو تجنب دودة الضغط المفردة
ناروتو
لوسي تحب مع صور علامة السفينة
آه
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم